has lived in hiding for more than two
years she says police shot dead her
husband Manny a labor union leader after
raiding his office
I was taken away to the gate away from
my husband and when I got there I heard
a loud bang I knew Manny was dead
that happened on March 7 2021 when eight
other activists were also killed by
state forces on what's become known as
Bloody Sunday all those killed had been
accused of associating with communist
insurgents a practice known as red
tagging
it became widespread when the government
of former president Rodrigo duterte
created a special anti-communist task
force you get tagged
as a communist supporter member or
whatever and then the next would be
physical surveillance or online threats
and the next pattern would be you're
being killed or you're being arrested on
on trumped up charges that's what
activists say happened before Natty
Castro a local doctor was officially
declared a terrorist in late January
that same day nine activists were
charged with Rebellion
we asked the anti-communist task force
for comment but didn't receive a
response often red tag individuals are
charged with possession of firearms and
explosives you know in the past two
years a number of these cases were
dismissed by local Courts for lack of
evidence according to the human rights
Washington more than 900 people have
been red tagged in the last six years
believes his father Jory was a victim of
an extrajudicial killing after being red
tagged for years he was shot 14 times by
assailants who almost three years later
have still not been identified posters
were scattered across Iloilo city
telling him or telling the people that
this person my father Tatai is a
recruiter of the new People's Army now
Leon himself is facing charges of human
trafficking he's accused of recruiting
child soldiers for the Communist New
People's Army he admits he's an activist
like his father and says although he
fears for his life he's determined to
prove his innocence
Barney below Al Jazeera Manila